all right pamela
pamela where'd you grow up where you
from originally newton texas
newton texas and uh tell me about your
childhood you had both parents growing
up
um no my dad he was uh he worked
offshore and my mother was
very young when she had me
so who raised you my aunt
my dad's sister your mom was how old
when she had you
uh 15. so your mom was in your life but
she was just yes
she had helped with she was very young
the relatives helped out
well my dad took me from her
oh so she really didn't have a choice oh
i see
how was your childhood sad
that is sad childhood always wanted to
be with my mom
she was never there
what kind of stuff went on in your
childhood um
molestation um
i got beat on beat a lot
for no reason sexual abuse was from who
not my uncle yeah
and my aunt she used to uh she didn't
spare the ride
put it that way and you left home at
what age
um well 14 but
i got kidnapped i say kidnapped i don't
know maybe
maybe i maybe i really wanted to um
to leave but i didn't know by a pimp
in texas where was he from
he was from memphis tennessee
and how did that happen me and my sister
we went to a club
and well i wanted my sister to a club
and um
i met this guy and i i don't know i
think he put something in my drink
so i passed out and woke up in arizona
and what happened in arizona
um we got pulled over by the police
because we had a candid marijuana seeds
and um they let us go
unfortunately they let me go
and we went to riverside california to
score some
pills preludes bi-62s
and i ran away
from him so young girl living on her own
well his bottom [ __ ] was 40. she was an
older black lady
and we hit a lick at the holiday inn on
university and riverside
and after that we split the money and
i went one way and she won another
and what did you do then you worked with
another pimp or on your own or
um i met this guy at a bowling alley and
he introduced me to this little white
girl named
valerie and she's still my friend today
and um her dad he took in foster kids
and so i lived with him and i was doing
like freelance modeling
at harris gardens in riverside
and um freelance modeling
what is that well on the weekends when
photographers you know they come in and
they take pictures we have contests
and i was a miner so and you're
clothed they're naked or yeah naked
you're naked
and in bathing suits but these are just
guys with cameras that like to take
pictures of pretty girls naked
basically and they pay for that yeah
this this goes on in like a strip club
or anything
you know it's uh called harris gardens
it's in riverside
and it's like a jungle you just
when you go inside you don't you think
you're in a jungle somewhere it's not
you'd never know it was there it's like
tucked away hidden away
so you got back into prostitution after
that yes
did you recall your very first customer
as a 15 year old
i was in gauston texas
and young recall was an older white man
probably about 60
we weren't allowed to date black men
back then
so yeah he was an older white man
did you work with another pimp after
that uh yes
after leaving the first one um you
yeah i used to run around with michael
concepcion and
um benzoal
snake from long beach he's a
pretty notorious pimp he passed away a
few years ago
you ever been married yes
twice
my first husband was a pimp and i
married him so you married your pimp
my mother made him marry me and
he um he passed away the police killed
him in 1987
or 88 no 87.
i was with him from 85 to 87.
do you have children yes
did you raise them no
you raised your kids um my
friend of the family raised my oldest
son
and my husband he was very abusive
mentoring and physically
and i didn't want him
to be abused by my husband so
i let him stay with my a friend of the
family
and when i went back to pick him up she
hid him for me
and she i never got him back so you
don't have contact with your kids
yeah on facebook and on instagram
was the last time you saw them face to
face i've never seen my son
well i seen him when he was 10 months
old and my middle son
i seen him when he was 10 days old and
my little girl
she was 10 months old last night
no she was 16 because she came out here
to see me
is that hard for you to be separated
from your children
yes
yeah i'm missing
what was the best part of your life
um the best part of my life
where were you happiest um i was in
when i was married you know
i was married to my husband i was i was
happy until
um i went to prison
for a hit-and-run injury
so that like took me away for a few
years
were drugs or alcohol a part of your
life ever um yes
i was a heroin addict
heroin it's the only thing that really
like
numb me you know physically mentally
emotionally
yeah do you still use today i chip
and you still work as a prostitute today
yes when i have to
[Music]
everybody where do you work now i figure
um figueroa
right here on town and
i've been all over the place san
francisco
cap street um out in the valley
sapoda sunset but i remember when
figueroa wasn't even a track
um broadway in central
was the track back then
what do you think is it about that
lifestyle that makes it so difficult to
break away from
um the money easy fast money
it's easy money
do you think there's anything in your
childhood the way you were treated the
the
sexual abuse or anything like that i was
molested by my uncle
you know they kind of like it makes this
easier right makes this kind of work
easier
yeah you're always used to it
so it kind of opens the door for it and
then
from there yeah and my one of my
wife-in-laws got killed
before my husband did and um my first
husband
and she um she was 411
she um she was a pretty little black
girl
and she got killed and i found her in
the middle of the street dead
it like blew my mind so when i did
heroin
it numbed me i didn't have to feel
the pain you know your childhood gets
fixed you're
recognized everything gets fixed i felt
like i was back in my mother's womb yeah
i've heard that many times how did your
friend
die they ran over her
when we went back to pick her up she was
just laying in the middle of the street
dead
with her head busted open and like every
ounce of blood
drained out of her body it's horrible
you've had that experiences too yeah
what kind of stuff have you seen i've
had to jump out of cars
um going 40 miles an hour 50 miles an
hour
a couple times i've been beat with
clothes hangers
um all kinds of juice
i'm sure you've seen all kinds of
strange requests from your clients as
well right
mm-hmm yeah what are some of the weird
ones um
well this one guy in san francisco had a
crush fetish
and he weighed about 500 pounds maybe
more
and he just wanted me to step on a
muffin
and you know smash it in the sidewalk
like
this step on what a muffin he had a
crush
fetish step on a muffin that you would
eat
yeah and he got off on that he gave me
eight hundred dollars to do that
you're not even touching him you're just
stepping on food
interesting world
and how old are you now 55 55
[Music]
yeah how do you how long do you see
yourself doing this
um well i've been i haven't been doing
the past five years i've been
um i was in a relationship and it was
like the first normal relationship i've
really ever been in
and i wasn't doing it then
you know i was just with my
boyfriend but um now
i'm back downtown here
[Music]
and hopefully i get my housing this week
so i won't have to be out here that much
more oh so you're living on the street
mm-hmm again how long have you been on
the street since i was
a kid you know since i was 14 15.
you got married at some point yeah but
my husband
he was always traveling and because we
used to transport
cocaine all over the united states
and we would drive stolen cars to
guatemala
from through mexico if it were those
mountains
very dangerous and um
you know enrique his name was enrique
bonifaz that's my husband
my oldest son's father
do you work with a pimp today are you on
your own no i'm on my own
are you saving money i'm trying to
people put stealing from me it's hard to
hold on to anything out here
yeah is this is this lifestyle that
you've been living
for all these years does it get you down
sometimes it's depressing
it can be
[Music]
yeah it gets me down i miss my kids i
wish i would have been
been a mother to my children i would
never been able to
but i wasn't so but they're doing
they're okay
you know my daughter's 18 she's so
beautiful she's pregnant
i can't believe i'm going to be a
grandmother
did you kind of credit the
childhood you had the parents weren't
around and the abuse that you had to
take
is kind of leading the leading you down
this path yeah
yeah my aunt that raised me she was a
minister
so i mean i couldn't do anything
everything was a sin
or i would get beat it didn't matter
what i did
whether i lied or didn't lie if i was
bad or good it didn't matter
and she would just and she would make me
wear dresses to school
you know after she put me um are you
religious at all
yes yes
yeah i love god if it wasn't for him i
wouldn't
probably wouldn't be sitting here
talking to you
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is for girls that work the street
like this
um don't understand
that um when they
you know have a client or turn a date
that they enjoy it or that they're
getting pleasure out of it
guys think that because i guess they
think that they would
i don't know why they think that but
it's just
business it's not nothing personal
it almost makes you respect men less
after doing this right
no no no
[Music]
no i have respect from men it's just a
job i mean they're paying for something
that
that i'm selling they're giving me what
i want
so no do you respect men less because of
you know
these kind of interactions that you have
with men
um the abuse it makes me
not respect them
what was the worst time of your life
the worst time in my life i don't know
it's a whole lot of works times um
i think maybe the worst time was when um
the police killed my husband
i shot him five times in the back right
in front of me
they said he brandished a gun and he
didn't have a gun
[Music]
it was a one of those old cell phones
those car phones
do you think living this this lifestyle
has changed
changed you some way
um not really i've always been the same
but it's it has it's made me more um
calloused
maybe i don't show my feelings as much
as i normally would
i'm sure you use your intuition a lot
doing this right yeah i have like
a sixth sense like get i always follow
my gut instincts
you have to right yeah
i'm sure you could you consider yourself
a survivor right
you have to be right to do that
you ever stand back and just look at
your life and the situation that you're
in and just go man this is nuts
i can't believe i'm out here doing it
all over again
you know i didn't think i'd ever be back
out here again
you've been in love before yeah
your husbands no i was in
love with him i was in
this last relationship i had probably
the only relationship that i've ever
really like felt like i was in love or
you know swept off my feet or
something like that yeah
and how did that one end
i have i don't even know how it ended i
know i lost my cat
i miss my cat i miss my cat more than i
do him
because he he's very abusive you know he
was very abusive
in the end i never seen it coming i
never thought that he would um
treat me like that and he treated me
worse than
any pimp ever has physical abuse
you had a lot of relationships the
beauty i know because i always leave i
never stick around
i mean if somebody hits you you know
they're going to do it again it's just
it's going to happen again it's not just
going to be that one time
oh they changed it's you know it's not
going to happen again
because it will it's going to happen
again
how much schooling did you get i went to
the 7th grade
what advice would you give a young a
young girl that was
that's considering doing something like
this
i'm sure she's like in a you know she
has to be in a situation that kind of
makes it yeah i found girls out here
like
teenagers and try to take them under my
wing
you know and help them get off the
street
but if they want to be there that's
where they're going to be and nothing's
going to stop them
but i wouldn't advise it because it's
it's a
it becomes a habit and then you can't
get a job
where you make that amount of money so
you're never going to be
fast money you're oh yeah you're always
going to be
missing the money you know
especially if you're materialistic
especially
materialistic if you're materialistic
person yeah
i'm not thank god thank god my daddy
he didn't raise me like that what's the
most important lesson
you've learned in your life
um that you never know a person until
you've lived with them
at least a few years you can't just be
with somebody
uh for a few days and think that you're
in love and
i'm gonna be with this person for the
rest of my life because
they change people change
and um he had he had hiv
and
thank god i'm i'm
try i'm be free by the grace of god
but i just i don't know i loved him so
it didn't matter to me you know
so what other kind of sex work have you
done i've done
fetishes i've um
i think i've i've done just about every
anything and everything that there is to
do i've
i've did it i like um
golden showers um
i really don't like to hit people and i
don't like being spanked
but i will i will be sick
i like i mean i will do it you know if
the person pays me i'll do it
um but
i lived out in studio city in the valley
and
i got into porn and back in the 80s
when um you know gang banging came out
and
i've always been attracted to um
violence for some reason i'm not a
violent person
but i like i've always been around i
like being around people that were
and i've seen were you exposed to
something as a child that
maybe well my dad shot my uncle
so maybe that and my brother shot my
his best friend um in the chest
did you see those exactly yeah
so being exposed to violence as a child
yeah opens the door for that right yeah
i think so i take psych meds
today because i have i still have
horrific
uh nightmares sometimes i wake
up in like a cold sweat and
sometimes i can't wake up you know i'll
try to
keep trying to wake myself up and i
can't wake up
so i just write it out
and but
i think being from the little town that
i'm from
helped me in a sense that when i came to
california
i wasn't as fast as um a lot of the
girls
are out here not so materialistic and
yeah not so materialistic like i like
nature and animals and stuff like that
i'm not really into clothes and cars and
you know jewelry and all that because
where i come from south central you're
just going to get robbed anyway
you want to walk down the street with a
lot of jewelry on
would you consider yourself a happy
person
yeah i like to i love i'm happy i like
being happy
i like laughing i like to smile i like
to laugh
i like to have fun if i'm not having fun
i'm not
i don't want to go i used to say if you
ain't ho and i ain't going
but because that's when the three strike
law came out
richard allen davis when he murdered
poly class
i was in santa rosa when that happened i
talked to him actually
i got i did a 10-day ddu at um in santa
rosa's county jail
and i got to talk to him you know
and tell him give him
a piece of my mind
yeah what would you have changed about
your
childhood or your or your life if you
could
well i don't think i could change i have
changed it but i think that
if i could if i had a wish
i would wish that um i could be a child
again
my mother my father wouldn't have
divorced and
they would raise me yeah
because i'm hoping that you know my
daughter will break the cycle
you know i know she will
she will
all right pamela oh thank you for
talking with me
good luck with everything okay thank you
thank you very much
you